we start tonight and turn to joe biden
who after falling not once not twice but
three times
trying to climb the stairs on friday
enjoying
a restful weekend with zero public
events on saturday
and sunday and today once again zero
public events
needless to say as we have predicted the
biden blitz is
really getting off to a very spectacular
start
now following joe's embarrassing
stumbles the administration literally
this is my favorite they tried to blame
the wind
the wind blew i don't know what's worse
the three tripping three times
or claiming the wind blew over the weak
frail joe
you decide the president take a fall on
the stairs
is he doing okay so as you know it's
pretty windy outside it's very windy
uh i almost felt coming up the steps
myself he is doing
a hundred percent fine he hurt his foot
that was recently
broken at all he's doing great all i can
tell you he's doing fine
gust of wind i get blown over all the
time don't you all get blown over all
the time
uh are we supposed to believe that joe's
leg gave out
because of what was a calm breeze on a
beautiful sunny day
of course today gentaki had a slightly
different explanation we'll play that
coming up later in the program but first
back to the so-called
biden blitz usually that means a maximum
of one public event a day
and most of this week joe is going to be
in practice practice practice mode
for thursday's big press conference now
remember during the campaign
joe biden usually completely would
disappear
five to six days before any big event
like a debate
in between naps joe needs a lot of time
to prep and memorize his lines and study
his little note cards
this is especially true now that joe's
crisis on the southern border
has become so dire that even democrats
and even the media mob are
starting to speak out a little late as
usual
look at your screen shocking new photos
released you see those photos there
by democratic congressman henry cuellar
and they're showing appalling conditions
at the overcrowding
migrant holding centers as you can see
the biden administration is now
cramming migrants oh into cages
that's right again with plastic covers
it remember was joe and barack
they built the cages for kids in the
in when barack obama was president
remember 2014
in 2018 the media mob they lied they
said donald trump did it
and then they actually showed video from
the biden obama era at that time
joe had this to say about these
so-called cages
which again his administration with
barack obama built take a look
this administration's policy that
literally ripped babies
from the arms of their mothers and
fathers one of the darkest moments
in our history yeah well biden's immoral
cages are back
and now they're worse than ever zero
room for any social distancing not a lot
of mask wearing
some of the facilities are operating
well over 100 percent capacity
some over 700 percent capacity at one
holding center
migrant children are now turkey taking
turns
sleeping with tin foil blankets on the
floor
many not able to shower for days on end
the media is still unable to see the
inside of these cargo shipping
containers
you know the ones with the tiny windows
with bars where they're dumping kids
and now even fake news cnn is finally
comparing these conditions to a prison
cell take a look
you have more kids coming into u.s
custody but just not enough space
to put them in shelter so that means
that these kids are staying in border
patrol facility
for prolonged periods of time and those
are facilities
that are not intended for them they look
like jail like conditions
like prison cells with concrete walls
and concrete benches
yeah a crisis they caused they got rid
of the stay in mexico policy they
brought back catch and release
but according to the biden
administration there's no crisis
whatsoever
just like there are no riots over the
summer they want you to think that they
have it totally under control they do
not
they want you to know that they're
definitely not putting kids in cages
well it doesn't look like it to us and
for some suspicious reason
they won't let any of us see the inside
of
any of these facilities in fact they
won't let anyone in the media
so much as speak to border enforcement
officials
those officials will get in trouble if
they tell the media anything
they want all interview requests to go
through washington d.c
according to one prominent photo
journalist quote
i have photographed u.s customs and
border protection under president bush
obama and trump
but now zero access is granted to the
media
he continued there's no modern precedent
for a full
physical ban on media access to cbp
border operations and he's right across
multiple administrations
this program has been granted access me
yours truly
to border patrol facilities i've been to
the border 14 times i've been on a lot
of ride alongs
with officers i've been on atv i've been
on horseback
that was a sight to see i was in
helicopters
you name it i did it 14 times we boarded
patrol boats in texas on the rio grande
we visited crossings
multiple border crossings in all the
states across our southern border
we even toured a massive warehouse where
cbp
stored confiscated narcotics and drugs
it is massive the hard work officials
who protect our borders could not have
been any more gracious or transparent
and now the biden administration which
vowed to be the most transparent in
history
is blocking any and all access it's so
bad that even the folks and
fake news cnn and even ms dnc
are starting to complain well their
ratings are
tumbling now that donald trump's out of
office maybe they should have
msdnc fake news cnn picture of donald
trump
miss me at trump 2024
but take a look for yourself as the
situation at the u.s mexico border gets
worse the media is being kept from it
despite calls of transparency from the
bind administration reporters and
photographers
have not been allowed inside the
facilities the biden administration has
not granted
news media access to the facility citing
coveted restrictions despite the
president's promise and his inaugural
address
to always level with you blocking access
to the news media is not
leveling with the american people mr
president the biden administration kept
talking about transparency and we're not
getting any transparency here
with what is happening at the border
that we have to get those images from a
congressman who won't say where he got
those images
it is very frustrating now there is a
pretty obvious reason for the media
blackout
it's an unmitigated disaster a complete
total failure of leadership
and it was caused all of it and is now
being made
worse by joe biden and his
administration but don't take my word
for it
listen to democratic liberal
congresswoman sheila jackson lee
or as joe likes to say surely take a
look
we have a situation that is a
humanitarian concern
we do have issues with any number of
children the numbers are coming up
but i will say that the biden
administration has met with members of
congress
they have a plan the plan does not look
like it's
working at this time but you have to get
it implemented
now tonight this is not only a
humanitarian crisis it is
the situation at the border is also a
health crisis
covered a national security crisis yep
even people
on the terror watch lift list have been
caught by
yup border patrol and according to
foxnews.com
last month alone human traffickers tied
to dangerous cartels they made 14
million dollars
every single solitary day from the surge
of illegal immigrants now these illegal
immigrants who successfully make it
across the border
are apprehended by border patrol they're
now being released into communities
and then sent on buses under biden's
catch and release program
to every state in the union many without
any coven 19
testing and many without even a single
court date
i wonder if they'd go to court if they
did no likely
odds or no the byte administration is
also
shelling out get this a whopping 86
million dollars to pay for emergency
hotel rooms
for illegal immigrants kids in cages
kids in cargo shipping containers
covet outbreaks people on the terror
watch list coming across the border
facilities operating at well over a
hundred percent
a hundred thousand migrants apprehended
at the border last month alone
were on track now to have over a million
by mid-summer
but for some reason the vice president
some would say acting president kamala
harris
thinks that this is all so funny take a
look
do you plan to visit the border
not today
but i have before and i'm sure i will
again
i'm sure those kids in those cages and
cargo shipping containers are laughing
too what's so funny kamala
our borders are now less secure than
ever you and joe are the reason
cartels are making millions you're
helping them
conditions at border facilities are
horrendous
law enforcement has now stretched razor
thin
drug dealers human traffickers cashing
in
all thanks to your failed policies
that's funny
billions of taxpayer dollars will now
pay for all of this disaster
every single person needs to be fed
every person needs to be housed
every person probably will end up going
to public schools
when they're young kids that we're
talking about
and everything else health care will be
paying for that too
is that funny i don't find it funny and
tens of thousands of new migrants are on
their way
and by the way there are ten cities all
across the border in mexico right now
filled with migrants looking for their
opportunity to make the cross
it's complete total out of control chaos
the biden administration has no one but
themselves to blame
on day one biden stopped all border wall
construction
he's since promised amnesty he
reinstated catch and release
he's blocking the deportation of
thousands and on the campaign trail he
urged migrants
himself in his own words unlike the lie
he told georgie stephanopoulos
to come to the border and he vowed that
his administration would be ready to
welcome them with open arms so
is it any surprise that the migrants
traveling to the u.s
are decked out in biden campaign gear
one individual
telling reporters that he's making the
perilous journey
all because joe invited him take a look
would you have tried to do this when
donald trump was president
definitely not definitely we had the
chance
so did you come here because joe biden
was elected president
basically basically the main thing was
the violence in my country
and the second thing i think was joe
biden
you know it's like a letter not my hope
you know what i mean and of course joe's
going to be spending all week prepping
for the big press conference no plans to
actually
visit the southern border to talk to the
guys on the front line